a camera woman working for a media
outlet affiliated with RT was injured
during Saturday's clashes on the
colombia-venezuela border the journalist
in question was taken to hospital but
has since been discharged colleagues of
Nicole cram say an armored vehicle
almost killed her and she sustained leg
injuries they say the journalist was
wounded when a group of Venezuelan
National Guard members allegedly rammed
their vehicle through a crowd of
protesters as they tried to enter
Colombia the servicemen had apparently
switched sides the incident left
numerous protesters injured we're about
to show you the video of that alleged
ramming but be warned you may find this
disturbing
[Music]
[Applause]
our Rutley video agency managed to get
hold of a video said to show the
aftermath of the alleged ramming which
left the camera woman injured people can
be seen climbing over barriers on the
bridge while two armored vehicles of
stationary in the background
amid the scenes of chaos and panic one
woman is shown with a bloodied face
needy workers are finding themselves
increasingly at risk as tensions in
Venezuela escalate and a separate
incident a journalist is said to have
been heckled by opposition activists and
was forced to abandon her report the
crowd reportedly came became angry when
she said that the opposition were in the
minority the incident was captured on
camera
[Music]
[Applause]
you